er wirkt erschöpft nach seiner
nahost-reise und da fragen sie ihn
ausgerechnet als allererstes nach seinem
auftritt mit dem umstrittenen saudischen
kronprinzen bin salman
ob es denn nichts wichtigeres gäbe
beiden ist genervt immerhin tobt ja in
krieg mitten in europa um dessen folgen
energie und nahrungsmittel not zu
mildern so argumentiert das weiße haus
müsse man mit allen reden dieser krieg
ist für die beiden endlich der handfeste
beweis dass er recht hat mit seinem
großen narrativ seit über einem jahr
verbreitete er es bei gipfeln und reisen
auch im märz im königlichen schloss von
warschau
wir befinden uns erneut in der großen
schlacht um die freiheit der schlacht
zwischen demokratie und autokratie
freiheit und unterdrückung zwischen der
rechte basierten ordnung und der die auf
rohe gewalt beruht
deshalb liefern die usa jetzt weitere
heimers raketenwerfern die ukraine
beiden bild beweisen dass die demokratie
am ende gewinnen kann gewinnen muss
genau diese haltung treibt amerikas
außenpolitik im dezember lud er die
anführer von 111 staaten zum virtuellen
gipfel der demokratien natürlich ohne
russland und china aber auch ohne ungarn
und die türkei so sieht die welt
zweigeteilt zwischen den freunden von
rechtsstaatlichkeit menschen und
bürgerrechten und deren gegner im
autoritarismus aller moskau und peking
alte bündnisse bilden das rückgrat die
g7 die nato die quad mit japan indien
australien und den usa aber beiden
vernetzt die allianzen mit dem rest der
welt
die vereinigten staaten bauen auf
traditionelle stärker als zentrum eines
netzwerks von bündnissen wie ist die
welt noch nie gesehen eine kombination
aus selbstvertrauen aber auch demut
damit sie anderen zuhört wenn sie ihre
sicht und ihre wünsche ausdrücken
der elitäre club der g7 auch auf
vorschlag deutschlands endlich ein stück
weit aufgebrochen die gastländer in die
indonesien senegal südafrika und
argentinien haben zwei der gipfel
erklärungen von elmar mit unterzeichnen
das transatlantische bündnis verbindet
sich mit indopazifischen partnern
südkorea japan australien und neuseeland
und die kurz staaten schufen in tokio im
mai einen neuen wirtschaftsverbund mit
insgesamt 14 ländern darunter thailand
malaysia vietnam indonesien und die
philippinen
eine gratwanderung es soll ein
gegengewicht zu china seien ohne einen
direkten konflikt mit peking zu
riskieren
wir müssen ja bei klima- und pandemien
auch mit china zusammenarbeite gleiches
gilt für andere länder die auch keine
perfekten demokratien sind
deshalb kommt beiden auch nach saudi
arabien das von demokratie nicht viel
hält menschenrechte mit füßen tritt aber
der präsident sieht die welt am
scheideweg es braucht neue auch
ungewöhnliche bündnisse wie zwischen den
arabischen ländern und israel gegen
autoritäre regime wie iran russland und
china im ausland verspricht beiden
verlässlichkeit und stärke dabei gilt er
zu hause als schwach
ein netter älterer herr den man gern
fotografiert ein vernünftiger im
präsidentenamt und doch glauben 75
prozent der amerikaner dass ihr land in
die falsche richtung geht die höchste
unzufriedenheit seit 2011 beides
zustimmungsrate ist die niedrigste eines
präsidenten zu diesem zeitpunkt seiner
amtszeit seit dem zweiten weltkrieg
fiel hat mit dem alles überragenden
thema zu tun
die höchste inflationsrate seit mehr als
40 jahren trotz brummender wirtschaft
trotz niedrigste arbeitslosenrate seit
jahrzehnten
wir diskutieren das irgendwie
abgekoppelt von diesem globalen phänomen
der inflation
es kann niemals die schuld eines
präsidenten sein dass auch wir diese
inflation durch leid aber eine
diskussion darüber dass es vielen besser
geht als früher fällt schwer wenn eine
mutter kaum milch und eier kaufen kann
und ein vater kaum das benzin um zur
arbeit zu fahren
denn beiden an einer eingestürzten
brücke zeit wie seien 1,2 billionen
dollar infrastrukturpaket das land
voranbringen würde wenn er erklärt warum
ein großteil des geldes helfen könnte
gegen lieferketten probleme und
inflation zweifeln dennoch viele an
seinen versprechungen
wie gehen die herausforderungen aus
einer position der stärke an ich bin
optimistischer als je zuvor denn die
zukunft liegt in unserer hand
es klingt nach wunschdenken denn amerika
taumel zurück in die vergangenheit
zutiefst gespalten weil der oberste
gerichtshof bei abtreibung klima und
wahlrecht den erz konservativen
ideologische erfolge schenkt ohne dass
beides verhindern kann
schwach bleibt er auch wenn er eine
kleine verschärfung des waffenrechts als
großen sieg verkauft und ihm dann der
vater des ermordeten schülers joaquín
oliver die wahrheit ins gesicht ruft
seit jahren fordern wir da schon sie
müssen mehr tun
beiden müht sich kämpft sportlich gegen
das vorurteil an er sei zu alt doch
selbst ein kleiner sturz wird zum symbol
bild und die mehrheit der demokratischen
wähler will nicht dass der 79-jährige
noch einmal antritt bei der nächsten
wahl dabei ist amerikas demokratie in
höchster gefahr das zeigen die
anhörungen des untersuchungsausschusses
zum 6 januar wie nah das land dem
umsturz kam und wie schnell die usa
selbst abgleiten könnten in den
autoritarismus
angefeuert von einem krachend
abgewählten präsidenten dessen partei
immer mehr zu einem kult mutiert und der
unwidersprochen lügt dass sich die
balken biegen
unser land hat russland erlaubt die
ukraine zu zerstören und hunderttausende
menschen zu töten
wenn die autokraten hier die macht
übernehmen gewinn dann fallen wir in
eine zeit zurück an die sich die meisten
von uns nicht erinnern
in eine zeit die sehr finster war für
europa für amerika und für die ganze
welt
mit wieder gefundener stärke und
globalen bündnissen will joe biden die
welt stabilisieren aber die
innenpolitischen probleme werden
übermächtig wenn sein plan scheitert
scheitert auch er und mit ihm die alte
ordnung dieser welt
[Applaus]